[Música]
el presidente ruso vladimir putin acusó
a las tropas ucranianas de usar civiles
como escudo humano y de detener a
estudiantes rusos como rehenes el
mandatario señaló que ucrania bloqueado
a los corredores humanitarios aunque en
la segunda ronda de diálogos con este
país acordaron la creación de estos para
evacuar a civiles las partes confirmaron
que alcanzaron un cese al fuego tras las
conversaciones
una ciudad bajo el poder de rusia un
pueblo destruido y varias de las grandes
urbes bajo el asedio militar así avanzan
las tropas de moscú en ucrania la
inteligencia británica afirma que kiev
la capital sigue en poder de los
ucranianos
la unión europea ya logró un acuerdo
para conceder protección temporal a los
refugiados que entren a los países del
bloque más de un millón de ucranianos
han huido de su país para buscar refugio
en naciones vecinas y otro millón se
desplazó internamente según datos de la
onu
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es manejar a calle y es un
placer saludarlos y comenzamos con la
ronda de diálogos la segunda entre rusia
y ucrania que ya terminó y que se
realizó en la frontera de este último
país con belarús las partes acordaron un
fuego un cese al fuego temporal según
informó el asesor presidencial ucraniano
allí agregaron que se encontraran por
tercera vez y según la delegación de
ucrania llegaron a un pacto conjunto
para crear corredores humanitarios con
el fin de evacuar a los civiles de las
zonas de peligro este nuevo diálogo
llegó en un momento en el que occidente
acusa a rusia de querer elevar el
conflicto a un nivel nuclear algo que
moscú desmiente
el ataque que comenzó el 24 de febrero
está generando un impacto masivo en los
derechos humanos de millones de personas
en ucrania los elevados niveles de
amenaza para las potencias nucleares con
armas subraya la gravedad del riesgo
para toda la humanidad actual jimaní no
quisiera llamar su atención sobre el
hecho que está en las mentes de los
políticos occidentales que una guerra
nuclear está en curso y no en la mente
de los rusos y el presidente de ruso
vladimir putin dio una alocución desde
moscú en la que señaló de crímenes de
guerra a las fuerzas ucranianas sin
embargo no dio pruebas putin afirmó que
las tropas de ucrania están tomando
civiles rusos como rehenes mientras que
usan a los propios ucranianos como
escudo humano el mandatario agregó que
las tropas de moscú están creando
corredores humanitarios para que los
civiles salgan pero que los
nacionalistas de ucrania los están
bloqueando el líder del kremlin también
dijo que la operación en ucrania va
acorde a lo planeado escuchemos lo que
dijo
la operación militar especial se está
llevando a cabo según lo previsto con
los objetivos que nos hemos marcado
nuestros objetivos se están alcanzando
con éxito y con exactitud
trichet
antes de su alocución desde moscú el
presidente ruso vladimir putin conversó
telefónicamente con su homólogo francés
emmanuel ma com en un nuevo intento por
buscar una solución diplomática a la
guerra según el kremlin
putin insistió en que quiere que ucrania
sea un país neutral para no arriesgar la
seguridad de los rusos y afirmó que lo
que quiere hacer es desmilitarizar al
país vecino el mandatario le aseguro
amazon que si kiev sigue retrasando las
negociaciones el resultado sólo será que
moscú agregue más puntos a su lista de
exigencias por su parte el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr scheleske dijo que
quiere hablar con putin y señaló que ese
es el único modo de frenar la guerra
mientras tanto las tropas rusas avanzan
en territorio ucraniano al octavo día de
la guerra son cada vez más los
bombardeos en varias ciudades del país
en chernigov al norte de la capital
ucraniana la cámara de un vehículo captó
el momento en el que varios misiles
impactaron en una zona residencial
22 muertos han sido confirmados por las
autoridades locales tras el ataque y el
pueblo de bolt no baja en la provincia
de donges que está prácticamente
destruido según denunció michelle
bachelet la alta comisionada de la onu
para los derechos humanos oficiales de
defensa de eeuu apuntan que las tropas
de moscú están a 25 kilómetros de kiev
la inteligencia británica sostiene que
esta ciudad está bajo poder de los
ucranianos pero estos militares rusos
están a punto de controlar toda la costa
ucraniana que bordea el mar de azov
un edificio de apartamentos en llamas en
pleno corazón de la ciudad de mar y fue
un enorme agujero en el techo testimonio
de otro bombardeo en el principal puerto
ucraniano en el mar de azov la ciudad
lleva sitiada varios días siendo blanco
de cañones lanzacohetes y combatientes
del ejército ruso el miércoles la
artillería golpeó áreas residenciales
incluidos un hospital de maternidad y
una escuela hiriendo a 42 personas según
el ayuntamiento las condiciones de vida
son cada vez más difíciles
otra vez nos quedamos sin electricidad
estamos otra vez sin agua y seguimos sin
poder calentarnos
en una señal de que rusia está
preparando una ofensiva aún mayor ayer
lanzó un ultimátum a los civiles
ordenándoles salir antes del jueves por
un corredor humanitario pero las
autoridades locales los acusan de
impedir esta fuga si mariupol está en la
mira es porque este puerto de 441 mil
habitantes tiene una importancia
estratégica para moscú tras la captura
de gerson miércoles si cae mariupol toda
la costa ucraniana que bordea el mar de
azov pasará a contra el ruso y la toma
de esta ciudad permitiría a moscú
asegurar la unión entre sus fuerzas
procedentes de crimea y las que llegan
de los territorios separatistas del
noreste en la ciudad varios miles de
soldados ucranianos se han atrincherado
y resisten por el momento los ataques
rusos
los ucranianos que se refugian en los
países de la unión europea tendrán
protección temporal y permisos de
residencia así lo anunció la comisión
europea la noticia llega cuando más de
un millón de personas han abandonado a
ucrania según acnur y un millón más se
ha desplazado internamente de acuerdo
con la información de la oficina de la
alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos pero obviamente desde
la frontera que polonia comparte con
ucrania nuestra corresponsal pilar
cebrián nos detalló más de la situación
de los refugiados
estamos ahora en uno de los espacios
cerrados que se han habilitado para que
los ucranianos que acaban de cruzar la
frontera puedan pasar la noche y puedan
resguardarse del frío es uno de los
centros comerciales que hay cerca de la
frontera y como podéis ver en cada parte
se han colocado algunas familias donde
han colocado colchones y también están
dejando sus bolsas para que puedan
descansar antes de dirigirse hacia otras
ciudades de ucrania en concreto este
espacio se ha reservado para los niños
podemos ver que hay una pequeña zona de
juegos y algunos están
y al fondo junto a sus madres y es que
hemos conocido el dato de que la mitad
de los ucranianos que están abandonando
su país son niños son menores y es que
son ellos los que sufren principalmente
el drama del conflicto y es una cifra
muy llamativa porque la tasa de
natalidad del ucraniano es muy elevada
apenas se aproxima al 123 hijos por cada
mujer ucraniana pero esto encuentra su
explicación en que los principales
refugiados ucranianos que están saliendo
de su país son mujeres y niños porque ya
lo sabemos los hombres se tienen que
quedar a combatir tienen que atender a
esa orden del gobierno de que deben
quedarse para defender su país y unirse
o bien al ejército ucraniano a las
brigadas de protección territorial aquí
los niños ucranianos que se van a quedar
en polonia para poder asistir a las
escuelas polacas es algo que ha
anunciado el ministro de educación ha
dicho que apenas tendrán que rellenar un
fácil trámite con el que tendrán
simplemente que acreditar la edad que
tienen para poder
a la escuela y otro dato por ejemplo los
niños huérfanos en en ucrania qué va a
pasar con ellos y hay quien los va a
atender bueno pues caritas polonia ayer
hizo una evacuación de 300 huérfanos
sobre todo de la zona del este de
ucrania para reubicarlos en dos ciudades
del sur de polonia
ecuador se prepara para recibir a los
primeros 350 con nacionales que viajan
desde ucrania en el primer vuelo de
repatriación se estima que lleguen a la
nación andina el viernes este grupo hace
parte de los 708 ecuatorianos que ya
salieron de ucrania de un total de 800
según el ministro de relaciones
exteriores juan carlos holguín los
ecuatorianos serán la mayor
representación de américa latina' en el
este de europa muchos de ellos se
cuestionan si regresar a su país o si
prefieren permanecer en la unión europea
en medio de una guerra entre rusia y
ucrania nuestro corresponsal en quito-
gustavo ortega nos cuenta las historias
de familias que esperan el regreso de
sus hijos
danny está a la espera del regreso de
sus hijos desde ucrania las habitaciones
están intactas desde hace tres años
cuando daniela y sebastián se fueron a
estudiar ingeniería aeronáutica al país
ubicado al este de europa ahora han
emprendido el retorno huyendo de la
guerra la decisión que hemos tomado como
familia de que ellos vuelvan y que
danielle específicamente vuelva ya
estando por cumplir tres años allá en su
carrera de ingeniería de aviación es
simplemente para una tranquilidad y
obtener en ellos y recuperar en ellos
una paz mental y psicológica que debe
estar afectada danny visita diario la
cancillería ecuatoriana en búsqueda de
información se encuentra con más padres
que desean traer a sus hijos de vuelta
para alejarlos del conflicto entre rusia
y ucrania
leonel es otro padre preocupado recibió
una llamada de su hijo ha logrado llegar
a subir pero las noticias no son del
todo buenas como padre el dolor es
grande pero yo le comento que mi hijo no
regresa adecuados él no va a regresar al
ecuador
desde una sala de atención improvisada
la cancillería rastrea satelitalmente
los ecuatorianos e intenta convencerlos
de abordar un vuelo humanitario con
espacio para 350 con nacionales
recibimos muchísimos pedidos de que se
se puedan quedar en españa o en italia
les quiero les quiero decir de corazón
que regrese en ecuador que les pidan que
les aconsejen y poder anunció que no
podrá otorgar visas para estadía en un
país europeo por ello usted va a
prefiere salvarse de la tierra y huir a
su país no hay comida
el clima acompañaba bajaba muy difícil
aquí están los documentos de vuelta en
casa van y se apura certificar la
nacionalidad de sus hijos para que
puedan regresar en el primer vuelo de
repatriación que enviará el gobierno
ecuatoriano quiere regresen en este
vídeo están obligados a firmar un
acuerdo de responsabilidad ante el
gobierno ecuatoriano por permanecer de
manera irregular
en la unión europea
la otan quiere fortalecer su defensa
colectiva en los países bálticos que
limitan con rusia desde vila la capital
lituana los ministros de exteriores del
reino unido estonia letonia y lituania
enviaron ese mensaje esta es el
abrebocas de la reunión de ministros de
la otan que se ahora mañana viernes
además se pronunciaron a favor de la
aspiración de ucrania para hacer parte
de la unión europea insistieron en la
necesidad de intensificar las sanciones
contra moscú escuchamos lo que dijo la
diplomática británica
como dije necesitamos asegurarnos de que
la economía rusa esté paralizada y no
pueda seguir financiando a putin y la
maquinaria de guerra y sospecho que el
pueblo ruso sacará sus propias
conclusiones de esos
noticia y hablemos del 19 porque francia
relajó dos de las medidas sanitarias que
eran más polémicas en el país desde el
14 de marzo ya no será necesario
presentar la prueba de vacunación para
poder entrar a lugares públicos el
llamado paseo vacunal solo será exigido
para quienes trabajen en centros de
salud y en hogares geriátricos la
restricción se levantó luego de que
desde enero hubiera protestas contra la
medida además tampoco será necesario
portar mascarillas en la mayoría de los
lugares como lo explicó el primer
ministro francés yann castex la segunda
medida en la misma fecha queríamos algo
sencillo el fin de la obligatoriedad del
uso de las mascarillas en todos los
lugares donde todavía se aplicaba la
norma es decir en interiores excepto el
específico muy bien hay dos medidas que
continúan para mantenerse vigente el uso
de mascarillas seguirá siendo
obligatorio en el transporte público
colectivo colectivo fue ayer concluyó la
píldora contra el cob y 19 llamada molt
no pira beer ya fue aprobada por la
organización mundial de la salud la web
e s la agregó a su lista de tratamientos
recomendados para combatir el
coronavirus así se convierte en la
primera pastilla en tener el aval del
organismo internacional sin embargo la
recomendación de la ms es que sólo la
tomen los pacientes que no tienen
síntomas graves de kobe 19 y que tengan
un alto riesgo como los adultos mayores
o las personas que ya tienen
enfermedades de base
y continuamos con noticias de perú el ex
presidente alberto fujimori será
internado en la unidad de cuidados
intensivos en lima hoy lo trasladaron
desde la prisión en el distrito de ate
donde cumple una condena de 25 años pues
por ser el autor mediato de las masacres
de barrios altos y la cantuta durante
los 90 el médico personal de fujimori
alejandro aguinaga sostuvo que el
político tuvo problemas cardíacos y que
era necesario llevarlo a la clínica para
estabilizarlo fujimori de 83 años ya ha
sido trasladado múltiples veces a los
centros de salud
y terminamos con el sonido de campanas
porque varias iglesias europeas las
hicieron sonar para pedir la paz en
ucrania la catedral de nôtre dame en
parís tocó su gran campana bourbon en
madrid lo mismo hizo la catedral de la
almudena mientras una multitud de
personas veía desde las afueras también
sonaron las campanas de la iglesia
memorial del káiser guillermo en berlín
parcialmente destruida durante la
segunda guerra mundial otras catedrales
se unieron desde noruega hasta austria y
marca
aquí el final de las noticias ustedes
sigan con france24
[Música]